correcto son 25 es la primera vez en
nuestra historia que tenemos esa
cantidad ya eran bastantes hace cuatro
años y hace ocho años cuando hablábamos
del 13 prácticamente un aumento de un 25
por ciento de perdón de un 100 por
ciento que nos lleva a los
costarricenses a analizar y a pensar de
que los partidos políticos en nuestro
país han dejado de representar a grandes
masas sean particularizado mucho y eso
ha atomizado mucho el sistema de
partidos en nuestra nación
bueno usted ya estaba mencionando algo
al respecto pero hay estos 25 candidatos
y el porcentaje de indecisos sigue
siendo bastante alto se debe a la
cantidad de aspirantes en contienda oa
que las personas ya no se sienten
representadas por estos aspirantes no
hay de los 25 a ciencia cierta la verdad
es que son cinco o seis candidatos los
que tienen alguna posibilidad de pasar a
la segunda ronda tal y como lo dice la
encuesta que usted menciona y otras
tantas los demás candidatos
[Música]
en terna de candidatos no tiene opción
muchos de ellos van con doble
postulación intentando llegar al
parlamento pero utilizando la calidad
altura
presidencia con darse más en el caso de
los cinco o seis candidatos que tienen
posibilidades de llegar a una segunda
ronda electoral hay tres candidatos de
que hace bastante tiempo se mantienen en
los primeros lugares josé maría figueres
del partido liberación nacional el inss
el sabor ido del partido unidad social
cristiana y fabricio alvarado de el
partido de nueva república sin embargo
en los últimos días hay candidatos que
han venido presionando tanto tres
candidatos rodrigo chávez e different
side
josé maría villalta que ha medido
presionando pero todavía a pocas horas
de las elecciones a 48 horas de las
elecciones parece que tal vez lo digo
chávez tenga la posibilidad de disputar
es el segundo lugar llevamos tres
periodos consecutivos de con este porque
prácticamente vamos a tener segunda
ronda donde costa rica se acostumbró a
la segunda ronda bien lo decía expósito
introducción que nosotros tenemos un
margen inferior a muchos países de
américa latina sólo pedimos el 40 por
ciento
sin embargo aún
raro ya que el candidato que puede andar
más cercano de ese 40% difícilmente
supera el 60 por ciento de la votación
necesaria